making winning plays doesn't speak much
when he speaks it means so much he's one
of the smartest players I've ever been
around in my 30-plus years in the NBA
he's a leader and he's always there for
[Applause]
value play offs is in the finals when
the lights are the brightest and that's
what you expect from Andre every given
night
this year's Bill Russell MVP Andre
Iguodala all manases great people
remember this for a long time the first
warrior to choose to become a warrior
and really started everything along with
Stefan klay Thompson has got center
stage to talk about his teammate I guess
clay lost okay obviously it's a it's a
special night for dub nation we got one
of the greatest warriors in the history
of the organization back called the
Swiss Army knife well my favorite
teammates of all time he made you know
me Steph and draymond loons job so much
easier
as well as coach Kerr and all the
coaching staff so we're indebted to this
man for what he gave us and it's good to
have you back Dre and I can't wait to
see you Jersey and the Raptors one of
these days bro
on the bottom of my heart I want to
thank everybody that supported us
supported me my entire time here it
definitely feels like home every time I
just left but it feels like home
really appreciate you guys and
appreciate y'all being loyal bear your
fans my brothers will be back in action
full throttle next year to wreak havoc
on the league for 80 games love y'all
[Applause]